la cire déchirée avec peut rien n'avait un
must gero paris series oxford est dedans
le système se tient loin de leur quoi
crayon vert
[La musique]
moshe de mes chansons sont mais ils
les autres musiques sont restées tellement djihad
vérifier gasp shell
du plus souvent prendre au sérieux j'aime ça
produire de la comédie
plus demain compatible impasse pas là
rien mec
sérieusement toute l'expression de ses yeux
tous ceux qui passent
le mode air série est un moyen aussi ancien
cercueil pour la capacité sans tout glinda
quelqu'un et toi pas de labo
le comité voit quelques-uns de sa bombe
de tes plus belles couleurs
je pourrais réparer non il y a quelque chose à ce sujet je dis
valeur prop box est alors doit être propre
était tellement appuyé sur un tout est déjà
[La musique]
si vous nous montrez que j'ai beaucoup de téléphones
ce jury qui est l'école de bartlett
charlatan de masse
plus est très venu des chirurgiens mais
alors vous pouvez choisir ce turc d'hier
yundi li est probablement mort avec ça
une tasse de café thé que smartmax
fps et rayon
[La musique]
expulsé là mousse cellulaire tas de frais
vous avez probablement réussi à ne pas avoir de condensation
vraiment prêt
presse mais staff demain alors je serai
sérieusement vous ceci donc cela signifie à nouveau
en attendant de créer du matériel, ils ont peur
était essentiellement en vidéo
[La musique]
skier plus mince est ma police de la figure
a répondu
sierra à savoir ou arme chimique
le groupe de développement n'a pas la pâte
pour cela et à partir de là, vous comprenez ce problème
est la concurrence pour moi ce que g
voir l'utérus réprimandé pour le razr
x aussi un mélange d'aller
[La musique]